I'm Stuart Varney i'm harris faulkner
I'm Chris Wallace and this is the Fox
News rundown
Wednesday April 8th 2020 I'm Dave
Anthony a change at the top of the Navy
in the controversy over a corona virus
stricken ship we don't know all the
facts but I can tell you what I do know
and that is there was a failure in the
chain of command throughout the pacific
area i'm jessica Rosenthal a key side
effect of this virus shutdown is an
economy on the sidelines and that's
impacting millions of Americans I went
from making $70,000 and having kids two
best weeks of my financial career to
going on food stamp this week and I'm
cat chimp I've got the final word on the
Fox News rundown
[Music]
the seas got too rough for Thomas Mowgli
so the Acting Secretary of the Navy
jumped ship resigning on Tuesday
afternoon over his handling of the
crisis on the USS Theodore Roosevelt the
aircraft carrier now docked in Guam
stricken by the coronavirus more than
200 sailors infected Bret Crozier among
them he was the captain until mode Li
relieved him of his duty last week over
a letter that sounded the alarm as the
virus kept spreading on the ship
Crozier wrote to his superiors
requesting assistance that they were
unable to follow guidelines for
quarantine so the current strategy is
ineffective
the captain wrote decisive action must
be taken removing all but 10% of the
crew calling it a necessary risk we are
not at war sailors do not need to die
well the trouble is the cap that
apparently shared that with a few dozen
others and it got leaked to the media
so Crozier was reassigned letters should
not have been sent to many people
unclassified that was a mistake
it's a mistake that shouldn't have been
made because it's unfair to the families
of the people on the ship because they
get nervous and it shows weakness that
was President Trump on Monday who added
all of that about the letter aside his
career prior to that was very good so
I'm gonna get involved and see exactly
what's going on there because I don't
want to destroy somebody for having a
bad day this as the momentum was
building to get mode Li to either resign
or we let go Democrats like Joe Biden
were already critical of his firing of
Crozier then mode Li went on to the ship
Sunday and I've set the crew with a
speech some saw as crude how Speaker
Nancy Pelosi wrote captain Crozier was
protecting his crew calling for help
and sadly acting secretary mode Lee
failed to prioritize force protection
showing a serious lack of sound judgment
and strong leadership hours later mode
Lee stepped down
the Defense Secretary accepted the
resignation and Navy undersecretary
James McPherson took over we're gonna
get into all of this starting with how
it all started
the virus getting on board the ship well
obviously being in a warship you're in
close quarters there's no such thing as
social distancing on a warship whether
you're talking about a guided missile
destroyer like USS Cole or an aircraft
carrier that six feet turns into six
inches retired Navy Commander Kirk lip
all knows about bad situations at sea he
was commanding officer on the USS Cole
the warship attacked off the coast of
Yemen by terrorists in 2000 leaving 17
Americans dead and he knew it would get
bad on the Roosevelt absolutely because
unfortunately the nature of that virus
how quickly it spreads how contagious it
is that clearly is an indicator that the
commanding officer did raise the red
flags immediately to say we must get
into port sooner rather than later
we must need the appropriate amount of
testing kits and ability to isolate once
we arrive we need to get the crew off
this ship get the crew get the equipment
sanitized from the nuclear reactor to
the weapons compartments and aircraft on
out but also the ability for crew
members to be replaced they've either
get diagnosed or in that quarantine
period so that there are people on Guam
or the port they pulled any port they
pulled into so we would have that
operational flexibility that should that
aircraft carrier be needed for a mission
say China moving in the South China Sea
that it would be that national asset
would be available to safeguard our
national security interests all right so
captain Crozier was this letter out but
apparently shares it with quite a few
people and then it gets leaked to the
news media and then it becomes a bigger
deal and then he is relieved of his duty
when you heard that what did you think I
was absolutely shocked I think that it
was an overreaction by the Navy
leadership at this point in time I think
that we don't know all the facts but I
can tell you what I do
and that is there was a failure in the
chain of command throughout the pacific
area the Pacific commander Admiral
Davidson ordered that ship into Vietnam
for a port visit in a peacetime
environment knowing full well and having
the intelligence capacity and capability
resident in his command to know the
Jeopardy that he was putting that ship
in yet he said let's put it in there
anyway obviously it had to do with our
relationship with Vietnam trying to
develop them as a bulwark against China
expansion throughout the region but
nonetheless it was an unnecessary risk
whoever did the risk management analysis
on this clearly failed and there was no
pushback down the chain of command from
the Pacific Fleet Commander from the
seventh Fleet Commander and I think what
a lot of people also don't realize is
embark on that aircraft carrier on board
Theodore Roosevelt literally doors down
from the captain is a 1 or 2 star
Admiral who is the carrier Strike Group
commander
where's he in this process he's
considered what we call the senior
officer presently a float or sopa he
clearly should have been far more
engaged than what he was and there was
obviously a failure in command
leadership through the entire Admiral
ranks in this case when Captain Brett
Crozier was removed from the ship he was
loudly cheered by his crew two days
later acting secretary mode Lee went to
Guam boarded the aircraft carrier and
addressed those same sailors calling the
captain's actions a betrayal saying if
the captain didn't know what he wrote
would be leaked also told the crew he
understands they love their captain but
they're not required to and he threw in
an f-bomb in his remarks I was
absolutely stunned when I was on active
duty I worked for two secretaries of the
Navy secretaries Dalton and Danzig
during the Clinton administration and I
will tell you right now it was beyond my
comprehension that a Acting Secretary of
the Navy
say something that disparaging about an
active-duty naval officer in front of
his career that type of unprofessional
behavior by an acting secretary was
wholly inappropriate and prior to the
ship pulling into Guam after the port
visit in Vietnam when they were being
diagnosed with cases of kovat the CEO
was involved in daily press conferences
back with the Bureau of personnel the
Bureau of medicine they were working to
get him the kits the chain of command
was aware of the issue what I don't
think the chain of command appreciated
now and I ran into the same problem when
I was trying to describe the scope of
damage on board USS Cole following the
attack by al-qaeda is they didn't have a
true appreciation of the urgency and the
necessity to get some of the support
there to get the testing kits there to
make the arrangements for the ship to
get into port quicker than they were
directing it to to have the facility set
up to quarantine them so this is where I
think you see the failure on the chain
of command which then drove captain
Crozier to write that letter but in
writing that letter I think he to
somewhat failed because it would be my
opinion there were a lot more avenues
available to him to exercise within Navy
channels that weren't exercised and
secretary motley acting secretary mod
Lee saying he could have called me up
but that's laughable that shows you he's
clueless because a ship CEO does not
just pick up the phone call the
Secretary of the Navy at Pentagon and
hold a conversation that that that is
not how a chain of command works at all
the day before Thomas modally resigned
as what he said to the crew of the ship
made waves he wrote a letter directly
apologizing to captain Crozier his
family and the entire crew of the ship
and for his choice of words naive and
stupid
adding the captain is actually smart and
passionate and sent that alarming letter
on purpose
to draw public attention to the
situation on the ship that we talked to
commander lip hold hours before
or mode Lee's resignation and he was
among those not interested in hearing
him say sorry I do not has accept this
apology at all acting secretary mod Lee
had time after he fired captain Crozier
he literally had hours and hours to
think about what he was going to say to
that crew before he arrived and what he
said about that captain was done with
malice and forethought he is apologizing
because he's getting squeezed
politically he is not apologizing
because he believes it in his heart so
therefore I don't lend any credence to
it so what happens next what happens to
the Theodore Roosevelt still stationed
in Guam
if sailors on the island isolated you
have all those who are recovering from
the infection what what do they do I
think the number one thing the Navy is
in the process of doing right now is
number one making sure that that ship is
getting clean top to bottom here this is
gonna be the cleanest that ships
probably ever been in its lifetime even
though it was brand-new coming
commissioned into the Navy because it's
going to get a thorough scrub down to
get every single trace that they can
find of kovat 19 off of that ship in
doing so at the same time the Navy
should be getting ready or if not
already surging additional forces out
there on temporary duty to take over
positions that if necessary you have a
crew and an Air Wing available and ready
to go that should a national security
mission arise which obviously be driven
by China but if they have a national
security mission that ship can still get
underway and execute operational
missions necessary to safeguard our
national security but at the same time
we're also making sure that those crew
members are being taken care of
when you see almost 50% of the Navy's
active cases of kovat coming off of that
one ship that should be demonstrating to
the American people the ruthless nature
of this virus how quickly it spreads in
close quarters with these crew members
so I think appropriate attention is
being focused on it and now we just have
to hope what happens next in the
regarding captain Crozier I don't know I
feel still think that a lot of facts
need to come out and you know the other
day when they said well the Vice Chief
of Naval Operations is going to conduct
a an investigation into this that's
really Washington bureaucrats saying hey
captain it'd be wise not to say a word
because we certainly could find things
to punish you for should we need to what
where would where would somebody like
he's in limbo so what does he do right
now or does he just stay home or
wherever he's supposed to go and just
sit for a while first and foremost let's
go out to it thoughts prayers that he
will successfully and completely recover
from having the coronavirus right now
that that's the number one priority that
he should be focused on along with his
family once he's through that then the
administrative process is going to kick
into gear into how did this incident
even come up that drove him to the point
that he wrote that letter then we have
to look at the larger picture of what
things may have been available what
tools may have been available for him
within the chain of command that he
could have exercised short of writing
that letter and if he in fact were
backed into that corner because his
chain of command was failing him let's
not just look down the chain of command
with this investigation
let's look up his chain of command as
well - that Strike Group commander that
fleet commander that Pacific Fleet
Commander that Pacific commander and
find out why they weren't doing what was
necessary when they obviously have far
more tools available to them far more
communications channels available to
them and obviously those weren't working
to the benefit of that crew all right
commander lip Holt thank you very much
for joining us and we appreciate you
being here absolutely my pleasure to be
on again and for all those that are out
there as I like to say stay safe stay
sanitary but don't forget to stay sane
as well advice we could all use right
Thank You commander
thank you
[Music]
this is cat temp with your fox news
commentary coming up as millions of us
hunker down hide away and fear the virus
others are feeling all of those feelings
while also watching their dwindling bank
account while the deaths from the virus
are tragic the other tragedy here is the
job loss the fear over paying bills and
worry about the future will banks that
deferred mortgages or landlords that
pushed off rent expect full payments in
a few months
millions of Americans are filing for
unemployment right now or they're trying
to there are reports of overwhelmed
systems calls going unanswered Google is
offering some logistical help in New
York in California the current events we
are experiencing a large increase in
cranes filed and are extending our
staffs resources to keep up with the
demand state officials say they're still
waiting on federal guidance for
unemployment for independent contractors
which is kind of a big deal in a state
that basically relies on gig economy
workers total job loss claims so far
appear to be in the roughly 10 million
range could be higher though as people
struggle to finalize those claims and it
may grow higher still there are reports
that getting those small business loans
that you can only really get if you keep
your employees are slow in coming the
financial institutions in charge of
doling out the federal stimulus money
recently asked for Congress to provide
some liquidity to help them meanwhile
millions of Americans wait to get back
to some semblance of normal we're all
obviously dealing with just the loss of
work avi Liberman is a stand-up comedian
and screenwriter you know you look at
your calendar and all these jobs that
you had coming up and they're just gone
its evaporated and some of them you hope
will be rescheduled but there's no
rescheduling like I know Passover starts
so I was supposed to be in Prague in
Greece this upcoming week working there
so as upsetting as that is that I don't
get to go to those places you know I was
you know I view those as income
there's no rescheduling Passover and a
lot of friends of mine who are comedians
who work on these resorts that's not
gonna be rescheduled so that's just
income lost walk us through what
happened because for a while there you
know you had
plans to travel you have these Passover
plans to perform and by the way for
those listeners who don't know I mean
Passover programs are really big
business they're booked months in
advance it's thousands of dollars to
attend one this is where a lot of
performers make a lot of money walk us
through sort of how you started to
slowly realize that you were gonna be
losing a lot of your livelihood a lot of
your income yeah well I was basically I
was in Ireland doing some work there on
I also write films so I was doing I was
meeting with the production company
there about a film I wrote and then I'd
flown back to LA for a day and then I
had four shows scheduled in New York so
I immediately flew there and a colleague
of mine a fellow comedian so listen ah
being this sort of dinner party can you
just extend your ticket by a few days
and I said you're sure this is gonna go
he said yeah and this was just when sort
of I don't want to say use the word
panic but you know the more concern
about people getting together in social
gatherings occurred and I said you're
sure he goes yeah yeah yeah and then so
I changed my flight and then within two
three days he calls me back and goes
it's canceled they're not doing it and
that was sort of the first hint you know
and then I had to change my ticket again
so all of a sudden you know I had shows
that were gonna pay me money and all of
a sudden it's costing me money for
changing my flight back and forth and
that was the first show that I had that
was cancelled and then I got back and I
got you know someone showed me an email
from one of these Passover program
operators and it said hey listen we may
be canceled we're not sure yet and then
it sort of began to swell and I realize
this is this is gonna be a problem and
then it's you know it just it began like
dominoes they all began to drop and once
once one cancelled I knew all the rest
would talk to me about your income
though you know a lot of people are
suffering a lot of people are having
trouble making rent making the mortgage
they're worried about paying their kids
school tuition if they're if they've
gone that route some people are more
worried than that they're they're you
know they're struggling to put food on
the table I mean where what's your
situation I mean yeah they just did a
thing called that comedy gives back
where they had this big fundraiser and
you know I was just like you know I I
donated
at first because I feel guilty but I'm
like I think I have to apply for this
like you know and granted they're just
they're the you know they're giving $500
to people who qualify and just normally
I would look at that go that's not gonna
change my life though it's like a but
now I'm like maybe it will you know like
that's groceries that's food for however
knows how much I applied for and you
feel you know you feel guilty in a sense
and also like I'm normally the one who's
trying to give charity as opposed to the
other way around and it's I talked to
the woman you know my friend Jody
theorem who runs it and she said apply
you should ah be like this is what this
is for you know so it's just weird you
have all these situations that you know
I comics would constantly tease me I'm
very cheap to myself not to others but I
try to like you know they would jokingly
taunt me like when I'm in New York City
like I'm not taking a cab I'm taking the
subway I don't care you know I just said
to me it's a waste of money and they
taught and teased me I'm like at now
there's a smart guy me hoarding all the
money because days like this I don't
feel like such an idiot anymore but yes
it's still scared like I don't want to
dip into my savings you know normally I
thank God we'll have enough money in the
bank to like cover you know basic bills
and stuff but now it's like who knows I
don't know if I'm not working for the
next two or three months like I'm not
sure whether I can do that are you
filing for unemployment oh I tried it it
just it's the same like everybody else
like it just you can't get through on
the phone I went online and like part of
the process I think is it's you have to
call and it's just there's no chance I
tried I went online and looked at it and
it's some of it was a little confused
like I wasn't sure because as an
independent contractor it's it's not as
easy for me it's a little bit different
you know I applied for some artists
grant that my manager had sent me you
know I'm not counting on getting that
they're these small business loans and
stuff that you may not have to pay back
and things like that but it's you know
everybody's doing that so again it's if
you have the whole world doing it it's
you know I just saw a report that
somebody who called 50 times every day
for two weeks in New York and just
couldn't get through the last part of
their unemployment process was making a
phone call and you can't get through
that you know so it's just yeah you know
how much motivation do you have in your
everybody else can't get through there
well are you and are you hopeful that
you might get some of the stimulus money
this Kerr's Act money are you waiting on
that at all yeah I know I mean I paid my
taxes right they did
I think that's just sent into your back
account that 1200 bucks I mean I'm
hoping that I get that I mean I really
checked with my bank because it's just I
don't want the you know it's a little
bit too depressing that I can't go there
in deposit checks so you know it's yeah
you hope you get that but at this point
I think whatever help you can get take
it did you know you have to kind of
throw pride out the window now Mandy
Visser works in the Bay Area now but she
just moved there from Texas right before
the virus pandemic started to cause
panic yeah I went from making $70,000
and having two best weeks of my
financial career to have going on food
stamps this week so Wow Mandy how did
your life change in such a short time
span well I'm a corporate trainer for a
high-end restaurant chain so I move
around a lot and I've always I've been
15 years with the same company and I've
never ever felt I got never had job
security with this company because they
you know they've been showing success
rates and everything like that it's a
great job and then you know I didn't
think it was real this whole thing was
happening they were like other
restaurants are closing down or like
ours well in our salon and you know then
in one Sunday morning on the 15th it
just everything came to a standstill
so obviously life changed a little bit
but I have my boyfriend and she was
roommates that I was everything with
we're more concerned about the outbreak
though because we live right next to the
Port of Oakland where they dropped off a
bunch of infected people and you know
Sammy just goes like very much like New
York I take the train every day to work
so we've just really been staying you
know inside that's the hardest part so
I'm not an inside person I'm like that
check on your extrovert friend alright
see you what happened you when you say
things kind of came to a standstill you
what did you lose your job we yeah we
were furloughed we didn't think we were
going to close down and and he probably
wouldn't have had it not been mandated
you know everything closed down we're
doing to go orders and I'm helping with
that a little bit but now I've been in
hospitality for 20-some years this is
crazy I never thought I wouldn't have a
job right and what I do
I'm also an esthetician you know
but there's nothing's available I can't
do anything I don't want to have people
in my home doing things that I usually
could do to make size model funny I just
want to be around other people crazy did
you have you filed for unemployment I
have and I'm having a little bit of
trouble because I just moved here in
February and so I did file with
California but I was living in Texas I
travel for work so I don't know I don't
know if they're gonna give me any money
which is cut a little terrifying but I
have enough saved up for this to last
about two months and then we'll see well
what about the government stimulus money
are you hopeful that might come into
play for you yeah I mean fortunately
unfortunately I I like to travel I just
went to Costa Rica and I moved so that
put me in a little bit of it but that
also anything that they're gonna give us
is going to be helpful but I could
probably more money selling some of my
old purses and watches and things like
that but I'm okay we're grateful that
I'm definitely great for whatever the
government can give us but it is a very
unique situation because all my
roommates are also in the industry
servers bartenders we are all in the
same boat yeah and your company
specifically did have do you know if
they are trying to apply for like small
business loans to keep you guys on as
employees so they furloughed most of the
employees except for a few managers that
are getting half pay and yeah I mean
we're just kind of hoping that it
doesn't last too much longer I really
think that my restaurant will bounce
back I don't know about other ones do
you think though that you'll have a job
with this particular company when this
is over yes absolutely yeah
okay so there's some hope there's some
hope in the mix of all this that you can
maybe go back to where you were working
and resume life as normal absolutely if
it doesn't go on for another like I said
I mean I was like oh cool April that's
fine
maybe but like June July like I don't
know it'll be tough maybe finally of all
the things that have come out of this
you know how do you think life will
permanently change for you
I think people are going to take things
like this more serious this is like the
first time I think ever that if you've
ever had the government tell us to stay
inside and you know the virus could take
us out I hope just I mean as far as my
life everybody's life is a little bit
different you know I appreciate going
outside and handshakes and being people
and traveling all that stuff you take
for granted
Mandy Visser thank you so much for your
time of course thank you so much it's
the latest from Fox News podcasts to
campaign with Bret Baier with updates
from reporters on the trail and in
studio experts Bret keeps you informed
on the 20/20 race go to fox news podcast
comm and download the campaign with bret
baier now rate and review the fox news
rundown on Apple podcasts or wherever
you listen it's time for your fox news
commentary what's on your mind
during a recent press conference
president Trump brought out Mike
Linville better known as the my pillow
guy to announce that his company be
making masks to help combat the spread
of the corona virus the response to
Linda's potentially life-saving efforts
mockery mostly now I can't understand
how seeing the dude you'd only ever seen
Hawking pillows suddenly take the stage
and a presidential press conference
could be a little jarring what's more I
can actually also understand some level
of mockery - I'm a non-religious Gary
Johnson voter and even if I weren't
either of those things I probably still
wouldn't have been able to stop myself
from rolling my eyes at Linda's claim
that God himself had brought President
Trump to us in 2016 at the same time
though I think that amid all the eye
rolling no matter how Warren said it
maybe we missed the chance to talk about
something else that's quite warranted -
the way that private companies have been
making a difference in our fight against
this pandemic make no mistake efforts
such as lindell's are not just
commendable there
actually crucial in our fight against
the coronavirus I'm not saying that the
government has no role to play in
fighting this pandemic it certainly does
but the truth is far too much of the
conversation on this issue is completely
centered on debates around the
government response when reality shows
us that the government is only one part
of the equation
in fact the examples of private
companies aiming to make a difference
are far too many for me to list to name
a few cascade lacrosse a company that
specializes in making helmets and other
protective gear for athletes as now
making face shields for hospital
employees and first responders clothing
brands including Hanes and Gap are
preparing to start making masks and
other protective equipment and Neiman
Marcus has people sewing scrubs using
donate materials from jo-ann fabrics and
crafts a main base start up tissue plus
has been working around the clock to
combat the toilet paper shortage then
there's this Singapore's greatest
laboratories for example said it will
soon release lab on chip kits to test
patients for three kinds of coronavirus
within two hours four american startups
had also launched at-home test kits
until the Food and Drug Administration
unwisely demanded that they stop issuing
or testing kits this issue with the
government getting in the way of testing
is unfortunately not new goes back
months and I've written about that last
month yes the my pillow guy seems like a
dork it's fine to say that I just did
the thing is though he's also a dork
who's an American success story Michael
and Al is a former crack addict who
started his own company which grew to be
worth an estimated 300 million dollars
as of 2018 and now he's using his wealth
and resources to help get us through
this the whole thing is truly a
microcosm for the beauty of capitalism a
guy who came from the bottom worked his
way to the top and is now using what
he's earned to aid the country in a time
of crisis private efforts and solutions
and times like this are wonderful to see
they are after all not only helping us
to mitigate the public health crisis
that we're facing but they're also
helping us to at least reduce our
economic one
should all be celebrating this and most
importantly cheering for it to continue
I'm captain you've been listening to the
Fox News rundown and stay up to date by
subscribing to this podcast at Fox News
podcasts calm and for up-to-the-minute
news go to Fox news.com
love FoxNews click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust and click the FoxNews rundown
playlist for the latest episodes